in those tree functions right so we're
talking at these guys now just to
reaffirm what you learned for a couple
of years now that -1 doesn't mean save
the power of minus 1 okay so that is not
one on sine X okay it is a 1 but it's
short for inverse not for anyway just
don't give interviews now we've been
using inverse trig functions for years
okay so the question where comes your
mind why are we spending a whole topic
on it and why have we waited until now
okay what was the first time what kind
of problems did you have to do which
required these guys you know u9 okay
what could give me an example of a
problem fine yeah okay good sir remember
tree did start with measurement okay
before we started think about that
abstractly as functions okay so a really
classic example would be okay you've got
that kind of triangle and they'd say
find feel right now how would we call
that writer well yes you get another god
what is that okay but you don't need to
write because it's a right-angled
triangle so you can just use the fact
that the sine cos and 10 ratios refer to
sides in the triangle right so what
would you write first yeah good search
its opposite and hypotenuse relation to
the angular or after so you'd say sine
theta is that okay and at this point you
might have jumped straight to your
calculator but what you would put into
your calculator was this right so you're
kind of inverted commas taking sine
inverse of both sides okay and it would
give you the right answer like
what's an equal to 40 degrees or
something I worked out before 37 okay
you like that's in the Red Bull pipe
that's fine okay so we've been using
this for ages and I could rehearse it
with different kinds of functions so why
are we spending a whole topic on it and
why have I been building on it for so
long
why have we spent a whole week more or
less revising like the odd trick start
before we even get to this so where
you're taking your notes let me give you
two reasons okay for why we're spending
our whole topic on this so that you know
you have some justification in your head
for why we're spending so much time all
right number one um we don't really
understand that these functions okay
I'll give you an example what I mean
okay because you don't need to really
understand anything really to use it you
know the classic example is food you may
know know chemistry know biology so I
really exactly I don't know anything
about the technical details of the
process by which eating food then it
turns into energy ATP or whether all
that stuff means come in and how the
process of food works Riley should class
up this king is here so Clarkson I know
what to see you move too much do you
move to resize by that'll be since you
know one you better not just cait's
that's true but not gonna know he might
have something
just go if you have to bring it back
okay
now I just tried to draw an analogy
right you're like I need to be food and
not really understand how it works and
you can use inverse trig functions also
without understanding other classic
example if I gave you a different set of
tie let's make that less looking like a
right angle triangle okay
and I told you it's not to scale okay
now for instance if we knew some
information about this triangle suppose
I gave you this angle and let's see I'll
give you this side morning and let me
give you let me give say this side lots
of scale right now if I asked you to
find that angle okay if I asked you to
find that angle ah you run into some
problems you can use that wall to use
its use the same rule right but when you
use it ranges rules because they dark
you know eventually after you
formulations that kind of thing thena
doesn't just have one answer that comes
out at the end right Jim at VA what's
the problem with the same rule because
you have two answers are we given there
we call it the ambiguous case right it
could be a cute the way I've brought it
or it could be obtuse right depending on
where this side goes and all that kind
of thing okay now why is that why is it
that now I know you have anything
explanation right but like what's the
huffman geometry of it why is the sine
rule gives you one answer but there
might be two but the cosine one doesn't
okay now I know you can come with other
explanations for it right but I think it
really comes back down to this okay once
you understand the treat [ __ ] the
inverse trig functions you look at this
to say ah exactly I know why okay but
you've got to get to that point right
now secondly we have learn a load of
stuff since we introduced
those three functions that are apply to
industries in some really special ways
the big one of course is calculus okay
so differentiation and integration and
all of those kinds of things right how
they apply to the inverse trig functions
is very drastically different to the way
of pliers to trig functions okay
and that'll stay I'll take like a whole
week just ones own right so hopefully
that's enough justification